genius brain listeners this podcast is
brought to you by better help this time
of year can be a lot and it's natural to
feel some sadness or anxiety about it
but adding something new and positive to
your life can counteract some of those
feelings therapy can be a bright spot
adid all of the stress and change
something to look forward to to make you
feel grounded and to give you the tools
to manage everything going on I've been
using therapy for quite a while now and
I specifically have been using better
help specifically because it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to my SK schu find
your bright spot this season with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com genius
to get 10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com genius genius brain listeners
give yourself the gift of insane savings
this holiday season with mm's best
wireless deal of the year right now when
you switch to mintmobile and buy any
3-month plan you'll get another 3 months
for free that's 6 months of Premium
wireless service for the price of three
mint mobile that you order and activate
from home while saving tons on foam
plans starting at just $15 a month when
you purchase a 3-month plan seriously I
can't think of a better gift than
turning an overpriced Wireless bill into
just $15 a month with mint mobile my
friends is freaking fantastic save that
money baby what are you waiting for for
a limited time by any 3-month Mt Mobile
plan and get 3 months free by going to
mintmobile.com genius5 that's
mintmobile.com genius5 you customers
only additional taxes fees and
restrictions Supply see mintmobile for
details genius brain listeners this
podcast is brought to you by fume what
is fume you ask fume is an award-winning
flavored air device that gives you a
better way to break your bad habits your
fume comes with an adjustable airflow
dial and is designed with movable parts
and magnets for fidgeting giving your
fingers a lot to do which is helpful for
de-stressing and anxiety while breaking
your habit start the holiday off right
with the good habit by going to
trium.vira the good habit that much
easier start the goodh Habit at tri.com
genius to save 10% off the journey pack
today what's up y'all my name is uzuhan
I'm so excited for you to watch my new
music video lover boy it's the antidote
to the red pill hope you enjoy the video
I'll see you on the
[Music]
podcast what a
shame he's a
boy M what a
yeah he's a boy wow she left me high and
dry still got no tears left to cry
cry gave him my all I tried how used to
treat me wasn't right wasn't right yeah
no love for aover boy like me right when
I love go deep I can't play on these
streets baby girl I got places I got to
go with a room for two room for two I'm
making moves I know I'm ready to bloom
shorty I just want you our story could
have been a fairy tale but you [__]
that up we had a connection for real
[__] that up sometimes I believe it was
my fault but no I had to let you go to
let you go I've been stuck in my head
every day and night was it something I
said that wasn't sitting right why don't
you pick up the phone maybe I came out
this strong
I want to apologize being me way
too I don't know what I should
say 4 3 2 one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast we have uzuhan here
formerly known as J Han also my friend
James Han the rapper the artist himself
everybody congrats your [__] relations
right here move to LA by the way he was
a [__] National Chess Champion by the
way you [__] nerd huh huh what is
that how did you start in doing chess
okay so you know I I call him a nerd
because I'm actually jealous I really
would have been a nerd so like it's
actually tragic to think about okay so I
was in chess club from like uh um uh
sophomore junior like and parts of the
senior year is and there is this one
moment when I realize that being a nerd
is not going to get me a girlfriend I uh
I would have been a full out nerd like
probably weeb at this point how old were
you when you realized this [__] I I was
a I was like a junior okay I was like a
junior and I was hanging out high school
high school I was a junior in high
school and we were hanging out with all
these seniors you know and we're like
man these seniors are so cool man and
then um I don't know I just I had this
moment where I was like wait why do they
keep hanging out with us don't they have
like girlfriends and stuff and I
realized they can't they couldn't get
girlfriends and around that junior year
was when I was like you had one of those
glass shattering moments where I was
like oh I want a girlfriend man like I
don't think I can keep doing this like
nerd thing so I leaned into sports more
and it's like the big tragedy yeah I
mean it it definitely helped like get
girlfriends yeah but like now because
being a nerd is cool like every time I
walk around like L Tokyo I'm like or
whenever I go to those places where they
play Dungeons and Dragons or magic and
they're CRA literally it's so weird I
feel at home but when people look at me
they're they don't think friend they
think stranger but in my mind I'm like
yo this would have been me this would me
in another Multiverse you know like I I
love card games and all that dude man I
mean like high school is so different
from when we were experienced it and now
right it it is the time of the nerd and
it feels amazing I like I say this I
went to the you know the anime
convention watching all these people be
so happy doing what they do and what
they love and it made me so happy to
watch them be happy I mean they stunk
like hell but yeah it's got a little
smell when you walk into like the magic
the Gathering tournament's a little you
got a little a little under under flap
smells you for me listen for me I get it
I love anime too but I bathe you know
what I mean I brush my teeth
DB I you take care of your body yeah I
get mad I get a little upset at them
right I enjoy that they're enjoying
themselves but brush your teeth guys you
know what I'm saying it's okay you could
all you could watch one punch man and
then one punch your teeth I don't know
do something [__] wash that [__] what
are you doing it makes me mad right cuz
it's like there's no reason that you
can't watch and enjoy this and still
keep up hygiene yeah right and I
remember I I said this on a previous
podcast and then one person wrote he
maybe it's because of
depression depression oh [__] my yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah David I want to die
every day thanks and I'm like oh still
bathe yourself huh yeah in your face all
right you could be sad and then stink
free but the [__] were we talking about
oh you're a chess champion yeah yeah
yeah yeah I you know my when the Queen's
Gambit uh show came out I freaked out a
little bit cuz so when you play white or
black there's different openings that
you have yeah I want to know everything
don't be shy tell me everything I know
nothing about Chess so like you know
what an opening is it's like okay an
opening is basically a premeditated
sequence of you know different moves
that'll lead to a specific result and
strategy that you want in the chess game
so for me when I played white I would
always play um the Queen's Gambit
opening because I loved sacrificing My
my what is the Queen's Gambit open
Queen's Gambit is just a sequence of
specific movements it's like the Queen's
Pawn goes up and then the C pawn moves
up and then you
sacrifice um that the the space that the
pawn occupies so that you can get better
bishop and night movements like you know
step nine 10 later down the line mid
game and then end game stuff like that
it's a strategy it's a strategy yeah
yeah yeah like I used to I used to read
books about it like I read books about
you know cuz you got you're Tomer too
dude you got I am you got to go through
different iterations you know like
people say they play you know oh he
plays chess not Checkers it's like yeah
I've been playing chess for a long time
like I my mind just kind of thinks that
way I'm thinking like 10 steps ahead
like always you know um but I I love it
man I love I love that also like you
know I feel like I could be like a war
general or something like that you know
so for the when I watched chess like on
TV right I actually didn't know how fast
it is like what do you mean when they
when they were playing like speed chess
or something [__] like that that's some
[__] no speed chess is not from what
maybe it's different now but like when I
was in high school like speed chest was
not necessarily seen as like oh these
are like okay when Bobby fiser and all
them they're not playing spee chest
they're playing an hour or two hour
games okay cuz you got to be meticulous
spee chest is kind of like you've
memorized sequences and you just kind of
out with the other person so there's a
certain oh so that's a certain type of
it's like fast twitch muscles you know
and I don't know what the other one is
but but it's just a different muscle
that you're us yeah yeah so it's cool
but it doesn't someone who's really good
at spee chest might lose all the time to
somebody who's like really meticulous
and memorizes and and like thinks
through like 13 14 sequences ahead so
when you were in high school right and
then you were in the chess club were
there other girls in the chess club uh
yeah a few oh it's like kind of like
engineering like it's mainly all guys
and then you see one vagina float
through you're like thank god dude yeah
I mean I don't I wasn't like into those
gals you know they're nice girls but
this is this this is the difference
though right I think when we were
younger we had the our our geekiness
right and then we would always try to
strive for people outside of our
geekiness and it's just like that
doesn't work that way you know I mean
you don't now gamer girls or like girls
in the gaming world they're like very
attractive yeah I think I think they've
always liked this type of stuff and
they've always been that but they're the
ones that bathe so you know like true
they've always probably they were
probably the same type they were always
pretty they just didn't brush their
teeth and now because the internet right
these girls every girl from like 12 and
up they know how to do makeup it's kind
of wild it's I love going on Tik Tok and
having this creature put on makeup and
they look like a different person I'm
not making a judgment on looks I'm no
prize myself but I'm saying little
schmagel puts on a little makeup and
then all of a sudden Heidi Clum and it's
crazy what makeup can do it it is an art
well all these people they've always
existed they've always been in the when
we were doing you know whatever I used
to play Yu-Gi-Oh when I was like uh when
I was 14 nice you know what I'm say hell
yeah dude but I stopped that [__] after
14 I was like enough is enough you did
it way earlier than me I I I stopped the
nerdiness like mid High School I missed
out on a lot of I was still a geek and a
nerd like that didn't stop I'm still a
geek and a nerd now like 100% I'm in
that group that's why I get to call it
out because I'm a part of your community
you I mean I'll go anime you know one
for one with anybody you I mean I'm that
big of a [__] nerd however like I
said you know a little soap little this
here deodorant but like I said I enjoy
when people love what they do when I
find out you're like a chess so you're a
chess champion what does that entail we
just went to a lot of tournaments local
tournaments in Maryland and you known
some yeah but like you're playing like
11y olds 12 year olds you know Middle
School Protege kids so what am I going
to do I'm I'm taller than everybody I'm
going to intimidate a 10-year-old 100%
yeah I did that too it was nice whenever
I beat him like or sometimes because I'm
bigger than you I know like there's this
one time I intimidated this kid into not
making the right move like he was
definitely going to win like he was
killing me but I I started like
Whispering under my breath I was like
like sending threats I'm like bro I know
where you live see this right yeah
that's my type of guy right there dude I
definitely would have done that I
wouldn't even done it on the chest table
I would have found out where they live
before
four Psychopathic bro yeah I would have
just showed up just stared at them like
who is this guy he's like you'll know
yeah and then when we meet at the
tournament they see my face and they
just turn [__] pale yeah oh man and
and they we also played with clocks so
like after you make a move you got to
hit the clock clock what is the point of
the clock it's just to keep the whole
match under two hours so like you have
an hour every player has one hour to
make all your moves like from start to
finish d a chess match is [__] 2
hours 2 hours if you take the whole time
yeah yeah yeah but sometimes you know
people like to move fast and then they
make blenders and stuff and then you
know one time this one kid was so
nervous and I kept intimidating him he
forgot to hit the clock so after he made
the move he just like sat there and I
was like staring into his eyes and he
was like that's crazy not doing anything
I think I burned like 20 minutes 20
minutes off of his 1H hour clock so like
off of and it was like earlier in the
game you know so I was like oh shoot I
might win I ended up losing cuz I you
know he was like way smarter than me but
hey I got the 20 minutes off I just
stared into his soul and he was just
like this scar shitless yeah yeah yeah
yeah dude you should have [__] gave
him some real threats once you hit your
thing it's his turn it's like I [__]
dare you dude dude [__] dare I'm not
that clever man I [__] dare you to
make the right move go ahead The Right
Move might be the wrong move little
[__] yeah you get in trouble for that
for making threats yeah no nobody heard
me I I whispered it hell yeah dude you
just wrote little notes of like a
drawing of you [__] his mom you know
sometimes um you know the only way to
real flat like one time um my friends we
would use like uh when you make a you
know when you move a Checkmate we would
always do like a little W it's nerdy as
[__] we just be like oh here's my last
move that's [__] hilarious that's
[__] funny dude oh my God that's what
I'm saying like this is a world I don't
[__] know nerdy to do that like but
look think about it like this right you
say it's nerdy right but basketball
players do the same [__] but it's just
in a different sport so why the [__]
wouldn't you do that [__] in chess I
would have got my dick hard and move
that [__] with my
dick [__] yeah you like that you
[__] like this [__]
[__] there's only like other nerds so
my dick won't get hard to slack it away
come on it's the final move don't do
this God
ready I would have so I would have been
a [__] Menace you would have been
Menace yeah people wrote about me in
articles in the newspaper and you
couldn't say [__] cuz I'm just killing
everybody at chess damn bro dude I'm
going start chess and start [__] up
some 11year olds you should hly but if I
lose it looks really huh the cheating
with chess there's cheating yeah yeah
there was a guy who cheated against
Magnus Carlson with a it was like a
vibrating plug vibr yeah vibrating bu No
I um it was he put it in the in a kid no
no in his in his and his up his butt
right and he was cheating against Magnus
Carlson to beat him like Magnus Carlson
is the number one chess player in the
world yeah and so what he did well this
is I heard about this accusation you did
hear about this right um so like every
time he would make a move like his butt
would start vibrating to be like this is
the best move you can possibly make in
that situation wow damn that's a winner
though dude he's got the hard R if you
he that's the hard R that's what I'm
saying telling you people listen that's
going to be a t-shirt you got the hard
on dog and then it's just going to be a
picture of me drooling out of my mouth
dude let's go dude who's going to buy
that shirt and get
cancelled yo nobody's going to know what
that means either hey what does the hard
R mean deep cut bro yo that's that's the
kind of fandom you got the hard R in
your heart yeah dude that's [__]
tight but see the level of excellence in
order to be met you have to go to those
[__] extrem
you have to sit there for 2 hours and
get [__] just so you could be the
best player on earth do you have that to
become the best rapper on earth possibly
dude he said I hit this button oh [__]
oh [__] I was doing kles as you ask
me that's crazy though like I've never
you know why it's so cool to hear that
because I don't think I've ever reached
a level of certain Excellence at
anything outside of like kind of what I
do right m prior to this like prior to
like me trying out comedy doing uh
YouTube or whatever that it is and even
then I wasn't at the upper echelon but I
got up to like a million plus
subscribers yeah so that in and of
itself was probably one of the more
successful things that I did but it was
always later in life as a young kid I
have none of these stories like if
somebody asked you oh what were you
great at you know when you were younger
it's a blank dude there was nothing that
I was good at so when I talk about like
oh they go oh you're so talented I was
like maybe but you didn't know me when I
was younger
like I had zero Talent at everything
like I don't have a story like you where
it's like oh I was a part of a chess
champion group yeah you know what I'm
saying threatening little kids I don't
have none of that [__] damn that was
like my one that was my way to like
create significance for myself though
you know cuz I felt so like you know
like nobody so when you went from that
transition to this to the to what
basketball yeah yeah yeah yeah did the
girls start talking to you more I was
still fat and short so like it wasn't
really working for me never mind then
day yeah it it wasn't a true transition
it was AAL trans it was the fat and
short thing yeah I think that was the
issue you [__] just burned all of
your friends and your relationships
you're the reason why I'm not getting
[__] and you play basketball and it's
the same thing oh I'm ugly I hit my
growth spurt though in uh senior year at
high school what so yeah yeah things
Chang you before I was like 5 six you
went from 56 to 6 feet yeah that's
insane your knees must have hurt like a
[__] huh I don't even remember I just
just remember my voice started dropping
and I was like damn I feel like a man
now oh [__] I was just excited to like
lose all the baby fat and stuff like
that you had your trans moment that's
great dude became a they them that's
crazy dude yeah so you basic that's
amazing man so okay so you had your
transformation you went into sports then
how did you get into [__] music
there's where's that um so for me I grew
up in Silver Spring Maryland and I I was
around like a lot of like black and
Latino kids you know not many like
people like me so the way we bonded with
each other was like hip-hop music and
the whole culture so that's kind of my
forway into like music and all that it
was just like it became my identity you
know in like Middle School I I like
consider myself to be like hip-hop like
you know one of those School prompts
that's like James is blank you know and
people would be like James is you know
that was true that was true though you
know but I wrote my ass wrote hip-hop
you know like back in the day cuz it was
like the thing that gave me significance
you know like on a on a big picture you
know like if you look at it it was
either listen
to White narratives white people
narratives and uh you know narratives
Italian's fine Italian oh you're right
you're right you're right you know like
it was either Listen to Like Music and
culture from the white perspective or
the you know Urban black perspective or
whatever you know so it was my way to
relate to other people and find
connection and that was kind of and then
when you're around rap and hip-hop like
you always want to make your own lyrics
up you know so that was kind of my way
to like process my thoughts and did you
ever like battle rap people in high
school I wanted to but I was so afraid I
was I was there's too much material you
short fat dude they would just burned
your ass dude yeah I wasn't confident
enough to like burn people back could
you do it now battle rap yeah I I think
I could roast people a little bit but I
don't know if i' I don't know if I'm
clever to battle rap like that I just
I'm good at like maybe making catchy
phrases and top lines and just talking
about my emotions yeah okay that's not
going to work that dude never mind dude
never [__] mind dude yeah hey yo
listen I was crying in my room yeah like
going on like w and out EXC W and out
would I would not do well in something
like that I'm not witty enough to be
like that I just have like my uh uh uh
you know like roast per minute it's like
a very low you know RPM it's such a it's
like a different Beast though cuz I was
supposed to be on when when wild and out
came out uh when they refreshed I was
supposed to be in that first season of
the refresh oh yeah I said no I denied
it so yeah because I started up this
thing called JK news oh okay so we just
started that and it was that versus that
and then you know we're not going to
talk about pay but they were offering
[__] pennies you know and if you
stuck with them long enough then you
made good money later on but you know
this oh that's why a lot of them are
still on it was it was either work for
them or just work on the seven figure
company like no I'm going do this with
my friends for sure for sure I decided
to do that and then Tim Tim Tim took the
I supped to F and Tim [__] killed it
and to be honest with you I wouldn't
have never done as good of a job as Tim
did on that show Tim was very very good
on it like I loved his presence in it he
had like good taste his his he so
[__] well in that show dude there was
no way I would have filled that shoe as
well as he had it was it's hard you know
actually like um musicians if you notice
like rappers and musicians who go on W
out the delivery of like how comedians
do it it's it's not the same it's always
yeah it's a it's a Miss it's it's it's
Improv you I mean it's it's stage
presence right and you'll see this now
too where they I I don't remember who
this guy was I I should I always [__] up
his name so I don't want to [__] up his
name but he was the uh another kid who
was
online um he was like a YouTube kid that
they were trying yeah he was trying to
fulfill Tim's role gum yes rice gum yes
yes that kid and he did terrible yeah it
was really unfortunate and that's the
thing too like when you're comfortable
performing in your own room screaming to
a camera when nobody's there it's
different when you have to perform
perform on stage and then bro have you
seen Tik tokers or people who are like
um just like social media famous try to
perform in real life have you seen
examples of it I saw a few for the first
time you know like the past few years
and it's bad I'm like wow they're truly
just performing for this yeah you know
well like look there's no jump Cuts
there's no stopping and then looking
back at the footage and changing what
you're saying you have to be
entertaining and a and a really dope
personality on the spot and most people
now are not that right because like I
said we talked about it you're creating
a Persona behind the camera right and
guess what you have to be consistent
throughout a whole show you have to be
witty you have to do this stuff and like
my like you know and I told my other
actor friends too would they would feel
a certain way about ticktockers and all
these other people being successful and
doing what they're doing and now they're
coming in and taking their quote unquote
roles I told them they will never take
your role they're not good at what you
do you're not good at what they do they
can't do what you do they're going to
come in they're going to get those few
auditions and they will never book
anything and even if they do they'll get
one opportunity they'll [__] off and
disappear cuz cuz they're starting to
realize oh I actually have to do real
work here and then now I can't control
my own space I have to be good in the
now and that is so [__] hard going on
stage making jokes and being
entertaining is not for everybody
there's a select few that are really
[__] good like the Logan Pauls and
all those guys right they're good
anywhere but they're they're rare but
they always had a dream to go outside
right some of these guys they just
wanted to be famous here they never
really talk to people they don't really
have friends but they're have a they
have a great online community yeah and
so their online community presence is
always huge do you feel like it's
important for artists or people who
create to like go be outside and see
what connects with people do you think
that's important it's important as a
human being I think but in terms of your
actual creative space I don't [__]
know right because things have changed
so much I would say it was important
maybe seven or eight years ago I could
say defended at Le seven or eight years
ago but now twitch streamers they stay
in their room and they record 14 hours a
day and they don't have to do anything
but then you see them like in public and
it's just like they don't make eye
contact they're not really looking at
you they're being super awkward it's
just cuz they don't yeah they don't know
how to talk to a person and when they do
talk to a person they overdo it they're
the most obnoxious person in the room
cuz they don't know how to react and
they think that they're special so they
just try to be this big [__]
character you know yeah and it's just
it's it's weird right I don't know what
this next generation is going to be like
I can only hope that there's like an
emphasis on like being a human yeah
right so they're doing like I always
talk about this pendulum pendulum swings
this way pendulum will swing right back
yeah yeah yeah cuz there's so much
online activity now I mean the pendulum
is going to swing to like where you just
want iners experiences where like like
don't film this [__] just like be here
and be present you know there's a new
trend now where the the trend is uh
somebody started it's like hey this is
the new trend it's a challenge don't use
your phone for the first hour in the
morning like that's a challenge [__]
and like people are failing these kids
are failing they're I can't do this I
can't do this like that's not even a
challenge if I if I told you I could
give you $1,000 and you had to do this
for a month I think you could do it I
could do it here's a th000 bucks in the
first hour don't touch your [__]
phone easy I'll just stuff it away
somewhere exact they can't do it they
literally feel like they're [__]
dying so it's it's the wildest thing to
me I'm like I almost thought that it was
like a joke or a prank but it's a
literal thing that younger people are
doing cuz they're so addicted to their
phones yeah become a part of them it's
an extension of them if they don't have
this phone they're pretty much [__]
you know so like for me and my wife when
we go to the hot tub at night we don't
bring our phones we just sit there we
[__] sweat to death and we we talk to
each other we have an hour conversation
and that's what we try to do right yeah
but the moment of phone's there I'm
going to be on my phone scrolling
through [__] writing notes writing
bits and stuff like that so I mean if
you have Infinity in your pocket like
why would you want to give that up yeah
that's true too I mean I don't yeah I
guess I can't really blame them right
cuz it's why not if it's right there you
know what I did want to ask you about
and I did ask him before this podcast
and this is very important to me because
there's so many things that are just
kind of jumbled up in this topic right
when you first started as a rapper did
you start off as a as a Christian rapper
I did okay why did you choose that route
at the time that was I was just very
religious very passionate about it um
you know in my own personal life so I
figured that was the only way for me to
express myself and I teamed up with
samok and another guy Chung and we made
a Christian rap group and actually we
toured the whole world from like 2010 to
2016 so like wow it like was a whole
thing we actually at one point in
20134 um we were getting courted by
labels in Nashville like Christian
labels like do you know Laura dagel have
you heard of her no she is like the
Christian Adele oh really yeah like at
the time she we were going to be like if
we were to get signed we would have been
like the same Freshman Class you know
yeah or or another have you heard of
Toby
Mack Toby ma yeah like Toby mag was like
a big innovator you know at the time um
like those labels were courting us and
they're like we love your music it's so
Innovative at the time cuz we were
mixing like rap um and like um melodic
Jazz stuff you know like the kind of
stuff you heard some of the amp stuff
back in the day and ultimately they were
like hey I don't think this could work
out
we just don't know how to Market
you don't know how to Market you so you
know they didn't say it but they said it
you know we're like oh writing's on the
wall I see why can't you Market us you
know and they're like we just we don't
know you know we love the music so much
but we don't make sense so you know
like uh I mean to answer the question
like I I stayed in that Christian music
world because that's all I knew you know
as the years went on but I realized for
me like I actually don't I I I removed
myself from the Christian music and
world and just wanted to do the general
music Market
because I I just I wasn't making music
for like religious Christian people
anymore you know I if anything like my
mission back in the day was to like you
know as a young zealous Christian boy I
wanted to reach those who were not
Christian or meet people who like wanted
to have real conversations about life
and religion and stuff like that and I
kind of was unable to find those people
in the Christian music space it was when
I started doing like more General market
stuff where I was at bars random venues
you know meeting people you know and
connecting with them as humans that's
when I started having real conversations
cuz you know people would just be like
yo you know you went through a lot of
[__] but like how can you stay like this
blah blah blah that's like a very
typical conversation I'll be like well I
don't know you know I I go to church and
you I just like keep it real simple and
they're like why you go to church and
I'm like uh cuz I cuz I don't want to go
to hell like you yeah how about that huh
hey look you know what whatever it takes
yeah you know so I enjoy those
conversations cuz I I love having like
personal one-on-one real connection with
humans you know that's what I always
cared about apart from music was it a
hard switch to go from chrisan music to
regular cuz you know this a different
Circle dude you're talking about I've
lost a lot of fans along the way I've
lost a lot of like Heathen kind of I
mean it's not like okay the music I'm
coming out now they're gonna really not
like it like because I'm just like
fullon raw authentic mom [__] your
dad not even your grandma all that [__]
yeah yeah yeah yeah all that bro yeah so
I just get messages from people who are
like your lyricism used to be so good
but then you start cursing and now it's
not as good and then you write to them
what suck my dick I just I actually I
just say thank you very much for your
opinion oh you D you're very kind yeah
dude I once wrote to a fan and then he
unsubscribed for me because he wrote
something along the lines of he goes oh
you used to be really funny but all you
do is make fun of people which is what
I've been doing for [__] ever yeah
you're a great Ro and and I wrote back
to him I was like when you pee you dab
your dick with a napkin and then he
unfollowed me
immediately and that's what I do napkin
has a lot of Pies on them he tell man
soaks up a lot yeah and so I just kept
responding to people that way but for
every subscriber I lost I gained like a
100 so okay okay well because like also
too you know I don't care yeah I can't
care I just have to if I make fun of
somebody or something right and by the
way I make fun of myself way more than I
do other people right have to right and
I come from a world where making fun of
you is healing because everybody can
[__] get it right it shows that
everybody is [__] flaw and nobody's
better than anybody else you know and we
do it to like a certain degree right
certain people can handle it so we don't
give them too much right but if you know
you create content and they're like well
now you're hurting my feelings because
the people you made fun of I'm in that
group hey suck my dick from the back you
know why I actually damn it's long
enough for that yes hey respect um boy
capping no but do you know why I'm
actually grateful that I get emails like
that and messages cuz at least people
feel something what I realized what I
noticed with the music that I was making
up until this point there are a lot of
people who rocked with me because of the
message and I I'm so grateful for them
and I still am a Christian you know like
my beliefs religious beliefs are still
the same um but I started noticing that
I like I didn't think my music at the
core of it it's utility it should make
you feel something it is a mood altering
drug it should make you feel yeah yeah
yeah better worse it doesn't matter
osmosis if you feel depression you
there's a whole bunch of things you need
music to be create a mood whatever I
felt like my music was starting to just
be
frictionless and it was tied to like my
past relationship and like you know I
felt like I was losing myself you know
deteriorating myself and and losing who
I was and I I I started becoming this
person that didn't want to offend
anybody oh that's a tough place to be in
people who do that genius brain
listeners this podcast is brought to you
by better help mental health is mental
wealth my friends and if you're working
on your physical health you should be
working on your mental health as well
because I know that when I'm not right
in the head everything else kind of
Falls part so I start there first and it
really helps with everything else in my
life you know this time of year can be a
lot and it's natural to feel some
sadness or anxiety about it adding
something new and positive to your life
can counteract some of those feelings
therapy can be a bright spot amid all
the stress and change something to look
forward to to make you feel grounded and
to give you the tools to manage
everything going on and listen therapy
has been a great tool in my life uh and
you know just things just be getting
heavy sometimes I just need somebody to
talk to so if you're thinking about
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient being in flexible and suited
to your schedule all you have to do is
fill out a brief questionnaire to get
match with the licensed therapist and
switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge find your bright spot
this season with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com genius today to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com genius genius brain listeners
this podcast is brought to you by Mint
mobile give yourself the gift of insane
savings this holiday season with M
Mobile's best wireless deal of the year
right now when you switch to mmobile and
buy any 3-month plan you'll get another
3 month for free that's 6 months of
Premium wireless service for the price
of three Mt mobile issue order and
activate from home while saving tons on
foam plans starting at just $15 a month
when you purchase a 3-month plan
seriously can't think of any better gift
the turning an overpriced Wireless build
is just $15 a month by the way with all
that money that you're saving next
holiday comes around buying gifts will
be a lot easier there's just easy money
in your bank by Saving I love it use
your own phone with any Mt Mobile plan
is switch easily and Everly with e or if
you need a new device for Li lied time
gets 6 months of free service when you
buy a select device and plan see Mt
mobile has got your back for a limited
time by any 3-month mintmobile plan and
get 3 months more for free by going to
mintmobile.com genius5 that's
mintmobile.com genius5 you customers
only additional taxes fees and
restrictions apply see Min mobile for
details that always end up being the
most miserable person ever and that's
what I was yeah cuz like you're always
being tugged by personal opinion all the
time it's like I'm going to do this oh
but what if somebody says this I know
people like that right and those people
are the ones that I [__] hate the
most and the reason why is because those
people are always the most dishonest
people I've ever met in my [__] life
you have no Foundation to stand on
everything you say do and feel is based
on everybody else so what you say to me
now will change tomorrow because
somebody else said something and I hate
people like that yeah I have a buddy of
mine who my wife hates right She [__]
hates this guy and I understand right
he's he's got no spine he's no no this
is different he has a spine but she
doesn't understand why I'm friends with
him and I told her is but because of
this this guy in my life has been this
guy
always rain or Sunshine he's still the
same person you got to respect that you
may not like everything that he says but
I know what to expect out of him because
he is always honest and I'll take
honesty over everything because at least
if you do something stupid I can either
say it to you or I can navigate around
you because you're not switching sides
all how do the honest stay alive in La
you're going to get burned to the Stak
that's what I've always been told you
just get blacklisted like me
dude
and then you just end up creating your
own Community okay okay you know what
I'm saying you don't need to like bow to
everybody right you have your own
community and your own Community will
support you and and help you thrive in
the in the best way possible I know for
myself I will never get to the heights
that a lot of people think that I can be
because there's something that I have to
take away from the things that I love in
order to get to that point and I'm not
doing that I refuse like I said if this
whole [__] explodes right YouTube
disappears tomorrow I'll just go work a
job whatever who the [__]
I literally don't [__] there are
people who are so tied to like this
image of who they are like this is who I
am if I don't have this I'm nothing no
cuz guess what I'm going to die
eventually you're going to die I'm going
to die I let go of the idea of Legacy a
long time ago I used to be stuck on
Legacy so [__] hard what did legacy
mean for you like for me it meant that
everything that I'm doing now people
will appreciate for years and years and
years and I'm going to put a stamp on
this Earth that people will never
[__] forget guess what that never
happens for anybody anybody you could
say like oh well people still talk about
these people in history yeah they do
they don't give a [__] about them though
doesn't really affect their lives like
that and it's going to dissipate once
like the their lifetime like the
lifetime of the people who care now like
it it it's going to slowly Fade Into The
Ether best thing I ever heard was like
Legacy is the dumbest thing on Earth
because the only people that get to
appreciate it is everybody but you when
you die you don't get to appreciate the
Legacy did you hear what Kanye said
about like sidewalks or whatever he was
like he was like the person who created
the sidewalk genius I want to become
like that because you don't know who it
is but everyone gets the benefit and you
like created something that was like
valuable I was like wo that's Go I mean
Kanye is one of my favorites you know I
don't know how you feel about him but I
don't know anything he makes me laugh
yeah he's wild he's wild Bush hates
black people best thing he's ever
said literally the funniest thing he's
ever said dude this was a standup comic
dude he's hilarious pure comedy yeah but
like you know that that whole thing too
is just when I had that that moment it
was very liberating right
because I kept on trying to do things
that were too artsy too whatever I was
like why don't you just do things that
you [__] enjoy right and that's how I
started this podcast I was doing this
podcast not everybody was doing podcast
it was very not that many people yeah
and I lost like a million subscribers
like people left on YouTube yeah oh they
just like I don't I'm not here for this
stuff you were here I was like cool but
I can't dictate what I do in life based
on what you want from me I'll be
miserable yeah for sure I'll be so
[__] miserable and now I love
podcasting it's like the best thing I've
ever done because I get to sit here and
just talk [__] with people that normally
don't get to see yeah you know when I
was out making these like Vlog contents
or whatever it required a lot of money a
lot of production and it just got tiring
and boring at the same time and I just
didn't [__] care about it so for me
to be able to shift things and do the
things that the way I want like I said
if I live and die by what everybody else
says nothing's going to get done dude
and I'm just I'm the one that's losing
yeah while so it's like these people who
told you that this is where you were
supposed to be do you think they're
going to be fans for you forever they
probably won't right there are fans that
I have that are longtime fans but I
think they also appreciate that I just
do what I want to do they didn't they
weren't there for the oh because of
these videos they're there oh i' like
him and I'm just going to watch his
journey all the way yeah yeah I focus on
the 10,000 instead of the million now
and it and it's probably one of the best
things I've ever done like it feels
amazing you know what I'm saying yeah
damn it's beautiful yeah inspirational I
mean for you right uh the other thing I
want to tie this into like you went from
a Christian rapper to this and
especially like growing up in like a
traditional Christian family I mean you
recently went through a divorce right
and like how does that affect you how
did that affect your music how did that
affect your personal relationship with
your parents like the religion thing cuz
it's such a packaged thing well my
parents aren't actually I didn't grow up
Christian so yeah yeah yeah so I uh uh
religion was something I discovered like
in high school really yeah so my parents
huh was it a girl no I wish oh usually
it is no no cuz um when I think just the
way I was created i i in middle school I
was like what's the purpose of my life
why do I exist in Middle school yeah
yeah in middle school that's why my
parents you know they joke they're like
oh he's the emotional one because I was
always like what's the purpose of all
this you know dude dude my kid's an
alien that's what I would think dude if
my kid came up to me at the age of 11
going what is life I'm like dude I'm
going to have to kill this kid
yeah I it was like in Middle School when
I was like so life the way it's
described to me is I'm I'm born I go to
school I get a job get a house get old
die
like I kind of saw it that way and I was
like that's kind of a bleak existence
there has to be more so like for me I
wanted to find more meaning in my life
as a middle school kid so that's why for
me like what I mentioned earlier like
the hip-hop Community allowed me to like
get a different vantage point on what
life could be you know and maybe I could
find myself in that and I did you know
and from there you know like hip-hop as
a community and music and all that like
you know it did its thing and inspired
me and allowed me to learn more about my
myself you know but like it wasn't
enough like for me like religion helped
me to like ground myself and and find a
pathway for like a elevated um existence
or or Transcendence you know it gave me
a path to that you know why why
Christianity for me I was introduced to
I I was invited to a a uh a church in
uh High High School in nth grade okay
and I started going at first this was
the and I grew up in like a black and
Latino neighborhood you know so
it was my first four-way into like a
Asian an Asian-American Community you
know so first of all it was just like a
community center of like you know and
when you just walked in you like dude
look at all this
ass real I was like look at all these
girls man you just [__] just buried
your face in their [__] praise the Lord
yeah yeah th% man yeah and there were
like older dudes who are like like H
types you know like people I could
aspire to be you know like it was just
like a whole big experience so that just
kept me there and then as I like learned
more about the uh like teachings of uh
Jesus I was like man this is this is
solid to me and I um once I got into
college I I studied other religions too
and for me at the time you know my
studies kind of I just felt like it was
kind of lacking for me I've never had an
experience like that because I was born
into the the religion right cuz my
father's a pastor the whole Community is
Christian so I've never fell into a
religion after not believing anything
yeah so it must be like a weird
enlightening experience to feel that
were you well question for you being
like a pastor's kid like um did going to
church ever feel like a
chore 100% like doing the dishes it's
like similar you know or like mowing the
lawn you kind of go through these
motions right it's like you don't go
there because of God you go there
because youve just been going there your
whole [__] life and so when you it's
routine you know it's like what's Sunday
for Sunday's for church you go to church
you w and Sunday like they would make
food after church was over they have you
get the plate they look at you they see
how fat you are they double up your
plate you go down you eat that [__] you
know I mean you praise the Lord and then
I would pretend to praise God because I
just didn't care for it you I mean and
then later on as I got
older now religion is a choice yeah you
don't have the routine now it's like oh
if you want to go to church you go to
church you want to say you love God
believe God then that's a choice right
and for the longest time I just didn't
care right and even now I'm what you
call the lukewarm Christian right it's
the it's it's the threat that they would
always say in church yeah lukewarm yeah
you the lukewarm the lukewarm Christian
they always say that [__] to me right
they're the luk I'm like yes I am all
right but now for me like what I figured
out what I didn't like about church was
simply just sitting I hate sitting the
Socratic method only goes so far yeah I
just sit there I would itch now it's
like if I listen to a sermon I just I
just I don't go to church well I do go
to church every now and then just
because I like being around nice people
you know they just make you feel better
and then they come up they go good
morning like hey good [__] morning to
you [__] and you [__] shake their
hand praise the Lord they slap them in
the ass and you walk away and then
you're kicked out of the church but then
I I would I go there for that little
recharge but most of the time I'll
listen to a sermon in my in my earbuds
and walk cuz I pay attention better yeah
when I'm sitting I can't pay attention I
don't know what they're saying it's hard
bro honestly like I talk about it with
some friends like church would be a
different experience if it was like a
block poy or like a picnic or something
more engaging because you like I say
this because I there was a church I went
to and for a long time like I I saw
people all the time and we make time on
Sundays to be there yeah I realized in
the the years I went I never knew
anything about this dude turns out he
was like a really cool guy never got to
know that much about him but I thought
that was an atrocity like I always saw
him every Sunday and we never made time
because like especially in like the
Western American church people just go
in and out you know you just do your
little information download and that's
it there's no actual like there's little
Community Building except in like
immigrant churches they're really good
at that cuz they're they're a little too
noisy though dude these [__]
know everything about you that's true
they [__] all up in your [__]
business many is that Community though
isn't that like being involved you know
like yeah but sometimes they just need
to shut the [__] up like I cuz I grew up
in my dad was a pastor and stuff and I
was I was a youth Minister for a bit too
and they're just all up in your [__] all
the time dude and I hated that [__] like
and they would thing and look I always
paint a bad picture of Christianity I'm
only talking about the bad stories cuz
they're the most
entertaining like the good stories is
boring as [__] dude right the bad
stories are the best
yeah they would always do this [__] to
like it's Universal across all Korean
churches to maybe Asian amans or even
other churches but they would always use
God and they would weaponize him to get
free [__] out of you and I hated that oh
so it's like let's say there was like
something let's say I am a painter right
I paint homes and they go oh can you
paint the church I'm like yeah well
we'll work on the price they go no do it
for free it's like why it's like cuz
this is for God and I'm like yeah [__]
but I got bills to pay ho the [__] are
you talking about what the [__] are you
saying dude I ain't Jesus Christ I'm one
of his followers pay me you know but
then you can't even ask for and they
make you feel like a bad Christian right
and this is where sometimes that
hardcore Community becomes too harsh CU
cre people like to gossip so oh did you
hear David doesn't want to paint for the
Lord yeah you know he's not painting for
Jesus the Christ he's he only paints for
himself that's that's a sin sinner
that's a evil right here you know it's
the inside of the heart that's a number
one death right there you know and then
they would tell that person then
somebody else will come back and then
this other old Korean lady will come up
to me you don't want to paint the poror
Jas right I was looking at her [__] why
don't you pain for [__] Jesus you got
[__] two wrists and hands the hell
are you talking about but then there
would just be this thing that would
happen and this is where sometimes the
community gets too harsh right I'm not
saying that's how it always is but for a
lot of Korean people that went to Korean
churches they dealt with this [__] all
the time and I [__] hated it I hated
it so much so for me going into a church
listening to a sermon getting the good
word absorbing that [__] yeah doing my
good mornings what's going on here's a
couple of bucks God bless you walk out I
feel great right the moment they start
seeping into my personal life where I go
like oh I got like little PTSD you know
so my yeah especially from your P like
with your background I totally
understand that's why for me too like
when I was asking you about the whole
like divorce thing too dude when a
Korean Church gets a whiff of a divorce
oh bro sinner yeah you know yeah yeah
unfortunate thing about that is like I
haven't gotten too much of it but you
know like if people don't have any
context about who you are if they know
you're divorced they're like oh it's
probably your fault guy you know that's
I don't know if it's a Korean church
thing it's just maybe just like an
American culture thing yeah but that's
that's like a little bit of pressure and
like you know a little thing that I felt
you know post divorce like I've I've
definitely you know with my wife too
we've had our situations so where we
talked about on the podcast where we had
this moment where I was going to leave
her right yeah you what gets to that
point of you pulling that trigger right
cuz I don't know what that's like and I
I've been almost to that point but then
we reconciled our differences and we got
better from it so for you what was that
thing so I mean honestly like it wasn't
my choice per say like it wasn't that
was not my solution that I wanted I was
strong armed into it yeah so you know
ultimately I had to agree so I am
playing a part but that was not my way
to resolve our issues you know like a
big thing for us like you know I'm it's
it's interesting we talked about like
religious beliefs cuz that was kind of a
big reason why like for her like she was
kind of out I I would describe it like
this at the beginning of our marriage
like the essence of who she was you know
wanted Christian things Christian
marriage you know married a Christian
boy and at the end of you know near the
end of the marriage her Essence changed
you know she realized she was no longer
had held the same religious beliefs um
you know and didn't believe in marage
Nothing Was the Same everything is being
rewired in her you know she's like
trying to figure things out and um but
she was married legally binded to this
you know religious Christian boy so she
felt suffocated and trapped so the only
way for her to like breathe and and get
to the surface was you know to like go
our separate ways yeah yeah you know so
that's you know like for me my choice
would not have been divorce it would
have been like hey let's do more couples
therapy or like figure it out out let's
work on it you know like I'm I'm here to
the end um and I realize like it's it's
a choice you know with you you and your
wife like it's a choice every day it's
like am I going to choose to work on it
you know or you could choose not to I I
will say this though you know in my
opinion other people might disagree it's
like religious differences aren't
reconcilable because it's not just this
thing that you have on the side it's
your it's your moral compass it's how
you live and die by right so you know
these households that it has worked MH
right but there's always that little
disconnect and I've seen it in their
parents all the time yeah you know what
I mean and it's not ideal I would have
not preferred it yeah and then also too
you know having kids too it's like you
want to instill these similar values
into your children but then you have two
different entities that are are V for
two different ideals you know so it
makes it very very difficult I'm not
saying it's not possible but I've
haven't seen it work out as well as
other people think it does you know what
I mean so when I always tell people with
religion it's like you know have your
religious stuff however you want right
but consistency is always going to be
important yeah you know what I'm saying
like for me anyways right because my my
thing is too when people go and they do
terrible evil things you know and they
go and the next thing you see this Bible
verse on their [__] profile it's like
you don't have to put that Bible verse
on there dude you don't have to right
like for you you might put it up there
cuz you're it's for the public
perception of you're a better person you
know in your community but you know if
God is an all- knowing being he knows
that you're the biggest piece of [__]
and when you go up to those Pearly Gates
God's going to whip his dick out and
push that chest
piece all the way in front of your face
and it's going to be a [__] Queen
with a finger out like this and you're
going to go straight to hell if that's
really your religion if you think that
this omnipotent being knows you in and
out he knows your heart and it's pure
evil what what the rest of the world
thinks about you doesn't [__] matter
because God knows all so that's like
sometimes when I see these girls right
they're spread
with their [__] butthole just like
that which look no complain all right
like the delegation approves you know
what I seeing I got those hard R eyes up
there you know what I'm saying oh for
those who are new listening that is not
the nword hard R it's something way
nicer it's [__]
so I know I shouldn't say the word I
only found this out like five years ago
that it was offensive really yeah I
actually didn't know no way well it's
cuz like you're around comedians all the
time so you don't you're
like unattached from like Society so you
got say disabled now yeah so when I said
no well I said uh leard I'll say it in a
in French right so I said leard and then
somebody in the comment is like hey
that's super disrespectful that's very
like not PC I was like Oh I thought that
was the PC word right so I was like
what's what's the so I switched it up
right and I said mentally challenged and
they're like dude you can't say mentally
challenge I'm like what the [__] is it
and so I just kept [__] up so the the
the [__] go post kept moving
so it's not mentally challenged anymore
it's it's it's like learning disability
or something really or something else
like somebody could write in the
comments but yeah I didn't I didn't know
that but now on the internet people are
joking more about things so it's
becoming a little more like it's it's a
joke relax I'm not saying I use it
frequently I'm trying to be funny on
this podcast you know what I'm saying
but listen it's still kind of a funny
word to me it is I grew up at a
different time dude me too yo speaking
of like uh language I mean I was hanging
out with these like middle school kids
mhm and I thought they would just be
like the most PC police type kids no
they not no they're just like you're gay
yeah I'm like yo I mean that's funny but
I I thought you would like police me you
know like this is what I'm saying it's
so it's the pendulum swing bro it's the
pendulum swing totally CU we're tired of
like the liberal scream girls you know
who were like talking about
nothing she her person yeah exactly bro
that's my favorite dude it's it's such a
joke it's so sometimes I want to come up
to that girl just give her a hug it's
like hey man you're good dude like
you're fine H she does need a hug yeah
like don't you're okay you're good like
nobody cares about you that much you
[__] loser like relax when I see that
and this is not just that I'm not
talking about that as a topic per se but
anybody who feels like they have to
behave like that to gain attention and
feel important there's something else
with you you know what I mean like you
need a [__] hug man like genius brain
listeners this podcast is brought to you
by fume cold turkey may be great on
sandwiches but there's a better way to
break your bad habits we're not talking
about some weird mind voodoo from your
crazy neighbor talking about our sponsor
fume and they look at the problem in a
different way not everything in a bad
habit is wrong so instead of a drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit fume is an
Innovative award-winning flavored air
device that does just that so you get it
instead of bad fume is good it's a habit
you're free to enjoy and makes replacing
your bad habit easy and what I like
about fume is that it's super easy for
me to fidget with because your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and it's designed with movable parts and
magnets for fidgeting giving your
fingers a lot to do which is helpful for
de-stressing and anxiety which is what I
need when I'm stuck in traffic in LA in
my car so I always have my fume air
device with me in the car cuz it helps
me with my anxiety as I click click and
I move that thing around it's super dope
man I actually like it a lot you guys
should hop on this because it's going to
help you out my friends start the
holidays off right with the good habit
by going to tume.is and getting the
journey packed today fume is giving
listeners of the show 10% off when they
use my code genius to help make starting
the good habit that much easier start
the goodh Habit at tri.com genius save
10% off the journey pack today but the
thing is that people don't realize
nobody gives a [__] about you literally
nobody cares about you they care about
you in the moment because you're a topic
to talk about but after that nobody
gives a [__] they literally could give a
[__] Logan Paul recorded a dead Japanese
man in a in a [__] forest and he has
a billion dollar company now and nobody
cares nobody [__] cares everybody is
a moral derc dude and you guys always
pretend that you're better and you're
not you know what I'm saying so just
keep it a [__] buck when I was in
Hawaii dude there was these two young
Hawaiian girls calling each other the f
word dude the hard F dude and I was
shocked cuz they were younger you know
what I'm saying what's the hard F huh
huh you don't know the hard F hey Pete
say
it oh okay just tell me later wait what
it it sounds like forgot but oh oh what
yeah that's the hard F oh [__] to each
other to each other as a joking they're
joking around and I was shocked I'm like
whoa dude this is like when I was a kid
y Oh see it's not even in my lexicon
anymore I was like what word are you
talking about [__] yeah that's what
I'm saying it's it's it's some different
[__] it's a hard F and a hard R you yeah
it's a hard F left hard and forgot yeah
I see you know what I mean my God so
they're throwing these words around in
just they're not actually hurting people
they're not trying to hurt just youings
but these kids too they'll do this but
online they'll [__] on somebody else for
saying it that's so crazy yeah I I know
for a fact I know that's what they're
doing because they're scared of public
perception but once people just start
being honest with their shittiness it'll
all sort itself out for sure right 100%
I I don't defend any of this type of
stuff I'm just saying that this is how I
grew up right I don't do it anymore but
back in the day grown now yeah we used
to
just you know what I mean you wore pink
what's up f
word I didn't know you like penis Y and
then haha we would laugh and then we go
to a gay bar
yeah the life was great cuz in
Sacramento the gay bars were the best
they had the cheapest drinks and the
bartenders were the [__] nice and they
knew they knew what's up they would call
me the f- word all the time great and
then we [__]
nice love that but when you know for you
like like it's always interesting to
watch somebody who like went through a
divorce and see what the aftermath is
right because I know for you it was it
was hard right you had this perception
of what your marriage was supposed to be
like and it didn't turn out that way do
you see it now as something that was
supposed to happened that was better for
you or do you wish you could have
changed something uh well I mean it
happened a year ago so it's been a long
year of just like yeah self-discovery
and self-discovery healing you know just
like gaining my confidence back you know
all that uh I
think why did it wreck your confidence
well uh big thing like during the
marriage like I needed her to support me
and in her own words she said I was a
terrible supporter you know like after
everything was done and cuz I just
needed her to be like my in my corner
cheering me on sure your wife you know
but you know if I had a show or
something I re I told her be like hey I
would love for you to be here I really
need you there it would be really nice
please be there and you know eight times
out of 10 she wouldn't you know for
whatever reason reason she just didn't
believe in you or I I think it was just
she was going through her own [__] you
know but it's like maybe it was hard for
her to believe maybe she was just like
didn't expect the lifestyle to be like
this maybe it wasn't what she expected
she just didn't like the fact that I I
don't know I was also like you know as
an artist you have a lot of insecurities
you have a lot of things you're not sure
of for sure especially in the music
industry and for her you know I'm sure
it was maybe it was unattractive you
know I think about it sometimes I'm like
man maybe I became this like very
unattractive person because I was so
lost in the sauce maybe cuz I you know
it was like I wasn't sure what was going
on in my own career and then I'm not
getting the kind of support you know
that I would have hoped from my my
spouse you know and it's like this like
it creates this like whole uh cycle yeah
negative cycle negative cycle you're not
getting support anywhere you're not
getting and then I become like less of a
you know man maybe I'm losing some of my
masculine Edge you know maybe I I think
about it sometimes because I'm like man
like I stopped you know like being sure
of myself making decisions you know I
was just so unsure of everything you
know and it wasn't just the music it was
like what's happening in the marriage
I'm Losing Myself and I you know I'm
scared if I offend somebody you know
like it just became I became a shell of
myself you know and I do I hate that it
happened yes but I think I I'm on a
journey right now to you know love
myself better
um and love how how I'm made sounds
corny but that's really what it is I
mean what it does I'll tell you this man
it doesn't sound corny man it sounds
gay that's
right I'm kidding I'm kidding uh that
that those are the good days the good
old days those the good old bad days man
yeah bigotry but you know for
you like the the I mean I would say from
my perspective I always look at things
as not like oh this was to happen for a
reason it's I think it's better for you
I think so I think it's a th% better I
feel like the person you see now I I
like this version better yeah you see a
little more open you seem a little more
honest and a little more Carefree you
know you used to like tiptoe around
words a lot right it's probably the most
frustrating thing about you is like you
just you're tiptoe you're Mr tiptoe guy
and now you're a little more open and
honest but you still have your wits
about you you're still really kind so I
think that makes it also easier for
people to connect with you as a person
you know for your parents growing up
that you told me like they didn't really
emote well the problem with people who
don't emote you also don't get to
connect with people yeah exactly you
know yeah th% when you show your
emotions whether it's flaws or good
things or bad things that is like the
key to connecting with somebody and
sometimes people don't understand that
like they'll say I'm a good person right
I don't [__] I don't [__] you over blah
blah blah whatever whatnot how come
we're not that close cuz I don't know
you I don't know what's good about you I
don't know what's bad about you you just
exist and most people don't want
somebody around who just exists cuz I
could just sit here and talk to this
[__] plant behind me yeah you know
it's the same thing yeah yeah and if you
talk to somebody let's say I known you
for years right but I only tell you
everything about myself how I feel what
I'm thinking about but you don't give me
any of that back yeah in your mind not
for you personally but in your mind you
might think oh I'm a good person because
I I listen to everything how come we're
not close well it's because I don't know
anything about you there's no pathway
for connection yeah when you're when
you're not able to express those
constantly going this way exactly yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know so for you like
this is probably I I mean probably I say
it was probably the best thing that
could happen for you because I think
like it shows in your music it shows
what you're doing it shows what all this
other stuff that you thought that you
probably wanted to do that you couldn't
do because you had this dedication to
this old person who you were yeah right
that's exactly it bro you're it's so
poignant yeah so it's like I'm I'm this
guy this is who James is this is who
James is I want this but then if this is
James here he can't have this you know
but I'm not saying you could have your
cake and eat it too but there are things
in this world that are inherently that
you I feel like there's like a checklist
of things that you have to to do and if
you don't do it on your deathbed and you
go back and you say I wish I would have
done this that is going to be the worst
thought you have before you die for sure
I could have done this but instead I
chose to do this and I just never ever
want to feel like that and I think for
you you're kind of at that point yeah
man like all the songs that I'm I I
wrote after the divorce I have like a
whole album full you know and I'm going
to release them throughout like this
year and next it's like the most raw
honest I've ever been and I've shown so
many of my friends I'll show it to you
later too like the the common feedback
I'm getting is oh this feels like the
James that I know in real life and
you're just merging the two yeah to like
res you know and now it resonates within
me because it's very honest yeah like
you're an extension of yourself right
and that's what people want to feel it
may not be the full version of you but
if it comes from an honest place people
will always feel that stuff they always
feel it you know what I'm saying like I
think like that's the the route that you
should go to um I mean if anything else
before we sign off on this podcast for
you uh what was the inspiration behind
uh bone Appetit cuz before this before
this podcast is I'm going to have you
plug this and it's going to be in the
front of the video so what was the
inspiration behind bone appeti yeah so
bone appeti and lover boy those are the
two singles that um I came out with
first from the album um I just wanted to
make a song where I wanted to like
perform on a big stage like I wanted one
of those like opener set songs where I
could just like come out and rage so I
just wanted to create something like
that and I just had all this like within
me you know like not only from the
divorce but also like just my
frustrations that I had
being uh you know who I am in Atlanta my
frustrations with music and the industry
and entertainment at large there were
just a lot of things within me that I
was like man shit's [__] yeah and I
just wanted to get it out put it on wax
and and just express myself in a new way
you know cuz I mean that's not even the
most cursing per capita I have you know
but you know I language so interesting
in that way cuz for me like I didn't
grow up with these like restrictions on
language you know for me it's just like
a one pathway of expression yeah you
know so I'm like okay well this is how I
feel and this is true you know it's it's
it just is there's nothing when you say
[__] it just there's a certain thing
that resonates you know like people know
they listen I sometimes I listen to my
own podcast I'm like dude you you curse
a lot man like dude relax David what the
[__] but I just I love it I'm sorry I
[__] I it's a nice little Zinger yeah I
get it man it's you know even with the
cursing like have you seen this like
YouTube video where I think people were
in like a ice bath and a control group
was like one one group had to sit and
they weren't allowed to like say
anything or no curse words I think they
just had to sit there and they timed
them and then they timed a group where
they could curse and speak and do all
these things which group like stayed in
the ice water longer it was the one that
was cursing 100% dude sometimes the
devil inside you helps a little bit yeah
man you I mean it might be temporary but
sometimes it helps dude I I used to get
in trouble so much for cursing and I
just told I just told people straight up
like listen dude it's either I curse or
I suck you in the [__] mouth you got
to give me one one of the other I need I
need an outlet like I need to express
myself in a certain way and my mom was
funny too cuz she never cursed in
English but dude she cursed in Korean
like a [__] but she would hear me
curse in English like I remember we were
going so I was going to the store I I
had I had my parents business on the on
the weekends as a kid with them and we
were opening the door and the door
opened and it slammed on my fingers and
I said [__] and then my mom only heard
the curse word but she didn't know why I
said it but so she immediately started
whooping my ass oh my God right she was
like [__] [__] [__] just scream [__] and
then all of a sudden unloaded like a
[__] 14 piece combo on me blah blah
blah and I was like dude I smash SM my
fingers and I'm getting my ass beat oh
my God so afterwards I asked her and I
asked my mom recently why she did that I
was like why did you beat me up that
night she goes I thought you were
cursing at me because you got you were
mad that you had to come work with me
what oh my God this woman has zero
impulse control dude yo so she just
unloaded on my ass cuz she thought I was
cursing at
her I was like that's why you beat the
[__] out of me oh my goodness for a long
time I didn't understand why that
happened I was like what the [__] like I
got my and you know when you're a kid I
was like dude life
sucks but then at the time I couldn't
speak Korean so I didn't even know how
to communicate it to her so I was like I
don't even know how to say this so cuz
my Korean was so bad and the only reason
why I learned Korean later in life was
so I could curse my parents out so it
was you're Menace I love it I every day
I would watch Korean TV shows and I
would just like study all the time go
out to K Town at restaurants only
speaking Korean and then after a year
the CRA like a year or so I was talking
to my mom on the phone and this is when
I just started talking to on the phone
she was like when did you learn how to
speak Korean I was like I got a few
things I want to tell
you I went in dude I went in on her I
went in on her and my dad and then they
were just like they cuz they used to
always say this phrase they used to piss
me off it was you don't know what I'm
saying because I'm saying it in Korean
and it's like oh okay I do know now you
know you know and then I just started
going off on them and they're just like
holy [__] I don't even think they
registered that was going off of them
cuz they were so surprised I could speak
Korean yeah you know what I mean they
were proud but angry at the same time
yeah so it was it was one of those
things that was very good for us right
and those like those you know for you
these weird like traumatic moments help
for growth oh another thing I forgot to
mention like the reason why I created
like the music videos and the songs for
bonapati and lover boy was cuz I I felt
like after the the divorce I it was like
the end of an era like for me of like
not only like not giving a [__] but it's
just loving how I'm built and who I am
you know I felt like spent so many years
just trying to be that people pleaser
you know I I call myself an ex people
pleaser CU I I just wanted to please
everybody you know my former spouse you
know people in the industry religious
Christians you know all these type of
people my former audience and I wasn't
asking myself you know like what is it
that I like you know so it kind of marks
the start of just me creating stuff that
I like and if people don't like it you
know that's too bad you know and even
the videos that I invested all the money
into
it makes no sense there's no the return
on investment Roi is going to be trash
but for me kind of like what you did you
know you were mentioning about like
secret society I I'm doing it for myself
I spent thousands I spent 15K each video
15K plus you know that's a lot for me
you know that's a lot for anybody dude
yeah like I I saved up my money and I
worked with people that I've been
wanting to work with and just created
the best to my ability and and I love it
I'm excited for the videos to come out
and like I just did it from for myself
as like a like a hard reset you know
just to have it for like the art value
is that I I created it and I like it
that's it and that's very important too
and you know you don't know what the
general return is going to be obviously
like monetarily it probably won't work
out right and how it always is for any
new artist yeah right but at the end of
the day for you if it if it fulfills the
need for you as an artist then it's
going to it's going to it's it's going
to be very frugivorous is the word right
damn I use ferous that's a tight word
hey man I'm [__] in college baby even
though I dropped out it's all good I had
H units but you know that that in turn
will grow into something else right cuz
as an artist you kind of need to feed
that side if you don't feed that side
then it goes dead I say for you you know
before we ever sign off if my biggest
advice for you I think like your thing
that you're going to need to do the most
for anybody who's really putting their
effort in is that you got to promote
yourself like there's no [__]
tomorrow that is the hardest thing for
most artists to do because they feel
corny yeah they feel like they're
begging they feel so well cuz I know the
artist type you know what I'm saying you
have to promote yourself like you are
the best in the world and I say this
this is the advice from the hard R side
right I'm listen you got to go you got
to go hard R dude I want to see that
like Team Rocket from Pokemon you know I
me let me show you more white white in
my eyes you need to go full blast and
promote your stuff like it's something
that everybody's supposed to Listen to
If you don't do that nobody's going to
do it for you it's true right and think
about it like
this and I always tell young people who
always ask this what if only a thousand
people watch it that was a thousand
people that weren't watching before that
th will become a th And1 1,00 and2 th
and3 if your product is good right it's
going to speak for itself cream always
Rises to the top I've seen it time and
time again but if you're not promoting
yourself and doing it like you're a
rockar now be before you become a rock
star nothing's going to
happen it won't yeah cuz you're like I
said you're a reflection of your art if
you don't show that people aren't going
to believe it if you're not posting
photos and posting videos like you've
already made it then you're pretty much
done already want to see that they want
to see the life that they also want to
live in you so you're going to have to
go [__] I've changed that a little
bit like even even the you know like I
know dude you look like a Sketchbook now
look at all these tattoos I know bro
like I just acknowledged I think like
especially after the divorce I was like
damn I didn't work on IM I didn't put as
much emphasis on image as I should have
you know or like this perception of like
you know I don't know man just creating
some sort of persona or like having some
level of success or excitement about my
own life and stuff you know I uh I
resonate with that and like that helps
that's that's why I you know care about
fashion I love it but I'm putting extra
effort like I've been on my CrossFit
Journey you know making sure I look I'm
a hard body yeah you know making sure I
work on everything and that's that
single life too man yeah you got to be
presentable dude at all times at all
times man that's single life is rough
man like I I I only say this got peacock
your feathers up all the time it's just
I'm so glad I'm married now cuz I just
literally don't care like I don't care
I'm not saying that when you know a set
of cakes walk by I'm going to I'm not
going to walk into the bakery you know
what I'm saying I'm looking but I'm
window shopping though I'm only window
shopping only window shopping I'm like
damn look at that ass and that's it cuz
I'm still a man but I don't have this
pressure of like feeling like at any
moment like the baddest [__] can walk
by or my opportunity can walk by and I
got to present myself the best it's
tiresome bro the four I don't know if
yeah like into yeah going into the
dating world like having been monogamous
five years and this was like before
dating apps were really a thing it's a
strange world out there for me oh it CU
I know how to love a woman I know how
you know like I I know how to do all
that and then I see how people are
dating and roster dating and [__] like
that I'm like what does that mean I
don't I don't even know see this is
lingo we don't even know I didn't know
about it until you know like this past
year where people are like describing
these way you know and their like terms
of like talking stage and da I was like
isn't it just dating well that's because
those guys are [__] losers that's why
I'm sorry the person that overthinks
those situations are usually the ones
that aren't really getting anybody right
most people want to feel comfortable
they want to feel like they could be
themselves and like if you have to put
on a show it's going to be exhausting
man [__] all that [__] dude go out there
talking [__] get rejected a million
times and feel that fresh puss dude
fresh brand new Puss dude you know what
I'm saying I don't know what that's like
but I bet you is fantastic man this yo
no we don't kiss and tell out here oh
that's right hey that's his Christian
side you know what I'm saying hey but
God knows God knows about that fresh
[__] I understand praise the Lord he
made it he knows what's up yeah what are
we at time
wise wow that went by [__] fast wow
that was fast well guys that wraps up
this episode of The Genius brain podcast
all your socials all the stuff that you
want to promote say it now all right so
follow me on all socials uzuhan music I
got a new music video coming out for
lover boy and go check out Bon Appetit
it's a it's a great music video
specifically for lover boy how I say it
is it's the antidote to the red pill and
if you watch it you'll know what I mean
MH so go check it out all right now I
want you to do that promo like you
[__] care okay that [__] was lowlevel
as [__] put some energy in that [__] God
damn it I know your parents didn't show
you emotion but we're going to redo that
and I'm going to keep this shitty take
in here we
go one more time okay okay I'll tell you
okay okay okay so follow me on all
socials uzuhan music I got music videos
out Lover Boy and uh bone appetite lover
boy I'm really excited for it cuz it's
like the the antidote to the red pill go
watch it you'll see what I mean I hope
you enjoy the videos you don't hope
you're going to enjoy that [__] it's
probably the best [__] that you've ever
heard in your life listen I love this
guy's music it's fantastic I was
listening to it on the way here it's
gotten progressively better over time
I've seen your your albums get better
and better and better in terms of vision
sound and Vibe it's getting there it's
going this way so keep growing watch
this [__] and if you miss it out now
then you weren't there from the
beginning so go [__] yourself genius
brain every Sundays at 12:00 p.m. also
secret society scrt s o c Ty y.com check
it out fall line is out also if you want
to go on the Junie hype you know Junie
is franchising everywhere baby and all
of our franchises are mucho happy so uh
if you want to be a part of the family
check come check us out go check out the
jby link go to jby uh jish shop.com and
you can get franchising information
there if you want to be a part of the
family if you want to be cool then yeah
do it so see youall next time bye I
don't care bye